INOUT ,
RMERU
U, LIKHE
PRRAEM SAID
ERRUSSIA'SY
EDT REVERSIBLE AND CLD
CHINESE MILITARY ASSISTANCE BE
E  PERHAPS REVNG AT FOR THE
L, I THINK REQUESTING THE S ANDI
YE THEY ARE INUBLETHE RUSSIAN L
UKRAINE, IF CHINA WERE TO R A L.
YOU KNOW, WE WOULD EXPECT THAT
SEE LARGRUSSIAS MOVING
FROMN E
EATRE.
HERER TO GETHEELTROOPS.
SO WHERE ARE T NOW?
S AND Y GRPSIK NOTILLERUIA IS O
>> RUSSIA HA
HOAR
COYOINOU'RIDEOECIFICALLY, YOU H
W T IS T
E DO YOU THINK THIS MAY
BE?
>> WELL, THIO N MORE
COMPLEX THANVEHICLES AHI DRONE
THATTARGETING,DI T G THLOCATHEN
LEASMPR .
S IS AE
ANOTHER LOCATION
SU
DRONE TELLIN ARTILLERYE THDEM.RR
OF TRA N
PART.
N PAME CONCERN ECH WEAPONS B OER
FF CCKP E WALL
>>AY HISNTANGES.
LALE ND
WORLD.AT PUTIN WILL NO T RED BE
>> I SHAT CONCERTHINK MAYBE AM
HITLER DIDN'T USE THEM.
LAST MOMENT, DIDN'T TH.AND HIS
NUCLEA THES AT STAKE BUT
>> BEFORE OU G FAM SAID AT
AVE A TH RUSSI IS
NOT S A OF W YOU? AGREEPLETELY.H
TH. UNITED STATES AND
THINK, NEED TO